la Banque du Canada lance une
consultation publique pour la mise en
circulation peut-être potentielle d'une
monnaie numérique avec nous pour en
parler Annie Lecomte qui est professeur
au Département des sciences comptables à
l'UQAM spécialiste des crypto actifs
bonsoir madame Leconte alors qu'est-ce
qu'une monnaie numérique d'abord
différente d'un crypto actif comme le
Bitcoin par exemple en fait c'est une
cette monnaie numérique là elle aurait
cours légal au Canada comme le dollar
comme
les sous qu'on qu'on peut dépenser
effectivement donc elle serait gérée
elle serait vraiment encadrée par la
Banque du Canada et elle elle sera au
même titre que justement que ces deux
visa dont on parle donc elles sont
encadrées elles sont réglementées mais
elles sont numériques absolument et ça
veut dire quoi ça numérique ça veut dire
que elles ne sont pas tangibles donc
c'est pas comme un biais de 20$ qu'on
peut avoir dans les mains c'est 100% en
ligne si on veut 100% virtuel mais de
toute façon déjà une très grosse partie
de nos échanges financiers puis des
transactions qu'on fait son numérique
déjà non absolument c'est quoi donc la
différence entre les transactions qu'on
fait en dollars canadien en ce moment de
façon numérique et la création d'un
dollar numérique en fait la différence
c'est surtout accès vers par exemple une
tranche de la population qui est qui va
beaucoup transiger avec de l'argent
comptant par exemple donc ces gens-là
n'ont pas nécessairement un compte
bancaire alors cette devise là leur
permettrait de continuer à transiger
dans un monde où
on est totalement l'opposé parce que
comme je dis ça ça va être réglementé ça
va être encadré on n'aurait pas cet
enjeu de volatilité qu'on a par exemple
avec le Bitcoin parce que c'est une
devise canadienne à simplement une autre
forme et
cette idée là c'est qu'elle est vraiment
lancée avec l'idée de la réglementer et
non pas avec l'idée comme à l'époque
avec le lancement du Bitcoin en 2009 de
ne pas avoir à faire aux institutions
financières on se rappelle que c'est au
tournant de la crise financière de
2008-2009 qui a eu l'émergence du
Bitcoin donc le monde des cryptos actifs
qui présentent certains des avantages de
décentralisation et de non encadrement
par une institution comme une banque
centrale on ne retrouve pas ça dans
l'idée du dollar numérique non et
justement ça va même plus loin parce que
la Banque du Canada se questionne sur on
sait que les actifs numériques les
crypto actifs crypto monnaie Bitcoin
sont sur des chaînes de blocs
décentralisées mais là on se pose même
la question est-ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'avoir cette décentra relation
là parce que l'objectif
ultimement c'est un ne pas avoir de
tiers ce parti pour compléter une
transaction ça c'est l'objectif quand on
pense aux crypto monnaie c'est pas cet
objectif-là qu'on a avec la Banque du
Canada la Banque du Canada et cette tire
ce parti dans lequel on peut avoir
confiance pourquoi la Banque du Canada
fait ça ça nous servira à quoi d'avoir
une devise numérique une des une des
raisons c'est le c'est que on est en
train de se préparer ils veulent pas
être pris de court et se prépare console
la population à ce sujet-là parce que si
on voit qu'il y a un transfert de plus
en plus important vers le digital on
veut pas créer un mouvement vers les
crypto monnaie ou encore vers des
monnaies numériques d'autres pays où
l'on pourrait avoir une instabilité de
notre système financier donc ça nous
permettrait de garder le contrôle en
fait de l'équilibre du système financier
donc ça c'est une des une des raisons il
y a d'autres pays justement qui ont déjà
leur monnaie numérique donc on est un
peu en retard dans notre réflexion en
fait c'est que pour le moment la
réflexion 11 pays pour le moment aux
dernières nouvelles qui ont lancé ce
sont bon il y a la Chine évidemment qui
est un très gros pays mais sinon ce sont
des plus petits joueurs beaucoup de pays
se questionnent il y a même des pays qui
ont déjà déterminé que pour le moment
c'était pas une option qui était sur la
table donc il le regarde c'est un
dossier qui le regarde mais pour le
moment pour eux ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une priorité donc c'est pas qu'on
est en retard c'est qu'on se dit on se
prépare et si besoin est on pourra
lancer la technologie on se reprit à le
faire est-ce qu'il y aurait des enjeux
de confidentialité ou de fraude
potentiel absolument mais ces enjeux-là
seront pas tellement différents de ce
qu'il y a déjà dans les institutions
financières parce que le fonctionnement
va être sensiblement le même c'est à
dire qu'on va chercher à va falloir
respecter les tous les règlements
anti-blanchement d'argent tous les
l'importance de connaître le client les
fameux keywaïciens dont on parle dans le
système ça va être la même chose donc on
va s'exposer au même risque c'est sûr
que la le volet technologique peut en
inquiéter certains mais on est déjà dans
ce volet là à multiples niveaux on
allait transferts intérêts qu'on
travaille beaucoup avec ça les paiements
en ligne tout ça et donc on connaît déjà
les restes donc consultation en ce
moment et ensuite si on décidait de
lancer une monnaie numérique ça
prendrait combien de temps c'est
difficile à statuer et même la Banque du
Canada ne l'a pas encore statué parce
que ce qu'ils disent c'est ça dépend ça
va dépendre des hypothèses de travail
est-ce qu'on veut le faire nous-même
donc du Canada à 100%, est-ce qu'on veut
aller avec des partenaires alors les
partenaires pourraient nous aider si on
va avec les institutions financières
mais ils ont déjà les protocoles les
processus en place ça va aller un peu
plus rapidement mais tout est une
question davantage inconvénients donc
ils vont devoir essayer une des raisons
va devoir regarder c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle il consulte la population
ok on va suivre ça de près c'est très
intéressant ni le compte merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]